[Music]
to our other top story a child is dead
after being hit by a bullet at an
apartment complex thank you for joining
us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Brian Loftus another child was injured
it happened last night on Boulder
Highway near Harmon that's where
Victoria Saha joins us now live
yeah neighbors tell me they're always
kids playing outside after school but
today it felt different as everyone here
was still on edge after last night's
shooting
it was a quiet morning for the residents
of Town and Country Manor I live here
and it's just sad many still in
disbelief over the shooting that took
the life of a child seemed like you know
a lot of people in China police say just
before 6 30 Tuesday evening two kids
both under 10 years old were in their
apartment with their parents when shots
were fired from next door the bullet
went through a wall before hitting the
kids makes it all worse as far as you
know that little boy you know being dead
and everything I feel real bad about
that residents tell me they saw police
taking a child from the apartment and
doing CPR before Medics could arrive but
the child died at Sunrise Hospital
there's about like 20 cops here
saturated this whole back area from side
to side and there was it was just like
crime seat crime scene tape another
child was shot in the leg and treated at
the hospital
the residents also told me that Metro
Police was out here today along with
their chaplain to offer anyone who
needed support because of this shooting
reporting from the Southeast Valley
tonight Victoria sahab 8 News Now